craftsmanship has been democratized in
the sense that anybody who can get the
file can make a gun potentially from
undetectable materials hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer Friesen TV and today we're
at the 2013 global conference in Beverly
Hills and I'm talking to avi Reichenhall
he's the CEO of 3d systems one of the
leading 3d printing manufacturers in the
world
avi thanks for talking to us good to be
here you're one of the leading
manufacturers talk about the state of 3d
printing right now and what we can
expect in the near and far future we're
entering an era of their return of
manufacturing I think to America and to
Western countries because the future is
gonna be about the convergence of
automation cloud computing robotics and
3d printing and so there is an
opportunity now to localize
manufacturing to reduce Freight to
simplify supply chain and to basically
empower local communities to become more
self-sufficient and to basically have
people obtain a factory in the box
that's flexible or tooling is cheaper
lead times are faster and complexity is
free we're on the brink of 3d printed
guns can you talk about what this means
for the industry well what it means is
that craftsmanship has been democratized
in the sense that anybody who can get a
file can make a gun potentially from
undetectable cereals and a famous case
now is making the lower case of an ar-15
the reality is you could have done it 10
years ago if you're a good machinist now
you don't have to be a good machinist
you just need the file that means that
you know with this exponential and
disruptive technology we're gonna have
some unintended consequences we're not a
law enforcement agency we're not a
legislative body our job is to educate
sensitize we cannot stop these
unintended behaviors any more than a car
company can stop a reckless driver too
from getting behind the wheel are you
worried that if they try it if
legislators try to regulate the guns
that these regulations will carry over
into other parts of the industry yes and
as you know even within good intentions
there are
intended consequences so in my
experience sometimes legislators
overshoot so the pendulum swings you
know to the other extreme I'm hoping
that they'll be healthy debate about you
know how do we unleash creativity but
also make sure that it's responsible
creativity do you foresee any other
controversial items being printed other
than guns well I think that there will
be lots of other fields that will become
controversial from counterfeiting
exciting designs and violating people's
intellectual property or copyrights to
the whole sex toy industry and
pornography you know we live in a
society that you know there's lots of
brightness and there's also lots of
darkness and there are lots of shades of
gray and my sense is 3d printing is
going to mirror and reflect all elements
of society obvi thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us thank you
for giving me the opportunity threes in
TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer